nous tous mais
tout ce qu'on veut maintenant c'est de
sentir grâce à des vidéos tournées avec
leur téléphone portable
des dizaines de ressortissants
camerounais comme adrien un marin de 35
ans arrivé en ukraine il y a dix ans
témoignent de leur quotidien difficile
depuis le début de l'offensive russe on
a eu la chance de pouvoir fait c'est un
gros con à acheter du riz
la farine donc déjà n'a plus de temps
dans la vigne qui commence une fois par
jour
que quand on comprenait les enfants
puissent les traiter complètement des
familles et de nombreux étudiants
camerounais qui disent avoir sollicité
l'aide de leurs gouvernements afin
d'être évacués ils n'ont reçu en retour
que ce simple communiqué les appelant à
la prudence et à suivre les instructions
des autorités ukrainiennes aucun
rapatriement n'a eu lieu nous avons
appelé nous avons fait tout ce qui était
possible avec les ambassades les
autorités mais tout ce qu'ils nous
disent c'est d'attendre attendre
attendre et on attend mais en a pas de
nourriture on n'a pas d'eau on a très
peur à 5000 kilomètres de là dans cette
banlieue de douala la famille d'adrien
vie dans la tourmente partie en euros
pour une vie meilleure le jeune homme
subvenait aux besoins de la famille et
prenez en charge les frais de santé de
son père atteint de la maladie de
parkinson
regardez les informations ou discuter
avec leur fils yoann zap est devenu le
seul moyen d'espérer pour ses parents
espérer que les autorités prennent des
mesures concrètes ou évacuer les
ressortissants coincés en ukraine quand
tu envoies ton enfant d'aller chercher
pouvait ni te soutenir et guile et qu'il
est en guerre qu'est ce que tu peux
ressentiez nous sommes en l'air depuis
c'était le grand soutien de la famille
celui qui faisait presque tout pour nous
vraiment vous supplions
les ong les organisations
humanitaires et le gouvernement
camerounais de vous sortir nos enfants
de ces de ce pétrin depuis que la russie
a lancé le 24 février une attaque contre
l'ukraine
deux ressortissants camerounais sont
décédés